hey everybody happy Thursday
WWE's smackdowns all day ringing okay
here we are on a Thursday there's been
I'm Eric today we're gonna be doing some
WWE 2k 18 which we actually reviewed I
think it was I want to get his name
right Richard wake Ling gave it a 5 out
of 10 so there's that but we're gonna
have a lot of fun I promise you that so
we're on YouTube twitch GameSpot I'm
watching and monitoring your chat so if
you guys have questions I'll send it
over to my friend Ben here who has way
more knowledge than I do about this game
I do watch Smackdown and Raw from like
at least a top ten perspective that's
how I get caught up I don't watch the
whole thing because it's like two and a
half hours yeah it's a time investment
but I like catching up it's nice to see
what's kind of going on like a shield
getting back together like we had Roman
reigns and it's okay because we got the
chat yeah and then we even had Brees
angling yesterday yeah fantastic
yeah they did a Twitter Q&A if you're
curious about that at all I will post a
link to where you can kind of see some
of that back and forth uh in terms of
them answering Twitter questions so let
me send that over into the chat but
we're gonna check out some new modes and
ultimately end up in some funny rumbles
which I didn't even know you could kind
of like download just characters in this
game I saw you with like a Terry Bogard
at one point I think achoo Maya might
might look at how
different from most people's in that a
lot of people oh man I want to get
really into my the universe stuffer and
even stuff there this is sorry please
and my way that I repented is I want to
get dumb like cereal box mascots bite
each other you have plenty to take okay
but yeah so we're gonna we're gonna look
at like the new my player mode I'll just
go into it yeah that's good
I placed welcome to folio stuff
[Music]
there
yeah
if John Cena and Batista in the game I
would assume John Cena is they don't
know about all right what era Cena do
you like they've got your favorite we
can't see him that's the real issue
Oh is he just like that turn off the
music Andrew that's fair I'll turn it
down we're still equalizing things
though we do it live exactly it's alive
all the time I just wanted to hear a
Cena song I wanted to hear Bobby Roode
song
I don't these are the hits yeah keep
them coming
yeah fun times
glorious is right jib so good glorious
that beam is so good it is it is pretty
solid man this loading time though oh so
it's like a weird RPG where like you
actually walk around like backstage oh
really
and you like talk to people Prichard
Morales has different era John Cena's
why he's been the same the whole time
like roughly I was watching some old
Cena stuff and I was like oh yes you
dressed more like we can talk to you no
jerseys hey that's a pretty accurate
version of you oh it's Dante wait
there's no voice it's just okay it's
some some weird RPG business alright
what's up Jake welcome good to see you
thank you for tuning in thank you all
for tuning in
oh they're invading you hey look it's
Bray just hanging out back here in the
back Dave your woods famous I'm supposed
to be have you ever fought anyone back
here yet I bought Pikachu that's very
awkward alright go talk to the valet we
got we gotta find Vince McMahon's yes
okay that's all she had to say
great what's up ghost assassin
and played in the production arena it's
a good thing to put in a run button I
was like wait that is that act there is
it right oh that is the ride oh I
thought you were actually just joking
great no this is where we are I don't
know how long we're gonna stay in this
movie no we won't stay - oh is that is
that uh who's that in front of you is
that Roman oh not her not her - this
this person who's making the costumes a
wardrobe change no I think we like we
like our business you know this is my
Monday whoa those chairs yeah all right
is that Roman oh is that I don't know is
that ninja Roman reigns someone from the
shield I'm real worried about this who
is this man dude that guy looks cool
he's a company man good luck out there
thanks man he always has a Baron Corbin
look to him yeah without the you know
with a mask obviously what's up Jay
Roberts my dude help me out here there's
a lot of weird djs manager no we're not
here now I can't green-screen myself and
wearing a green shirt yeah where's your
torso how's the PC version not sure jib
we were playing on ps4 for any of those
that are curious look at this room it's
a very nice backstage room here I got
t-rex love dressing or in here that
might not have been if he writes head
but would it whatever it's gonna barge
into everyone's Hey hello here we go
yeah that's where you train - mm-hmm
they just perfect wonderful speak with
Baron blade where is he would you do the
right I think that's high whoa what are
you what do we have in today for lunch
surprise it's me it's time you're on the
mic we get some cool complements go
straight to their heads great okay
whoops see you later
or maybe it was down past the hall wait
could you even get past the photo shoot
no there's
oh sweet alright well this is my first
night at NXT and it's already gone bad
nah man come on how are you gonna get
that debut fight that looks like
security security tell me where to go
hi there map well maybe to your life
yeah yeah sure sorry
straight into your life okay hey is that
who are these people
I don't know like a weird John Cena the
green tie that one guy found okay nailed
a run down good things I imagine remains
to be seen I level of height moving
around me why is he so slow that's a
good question hunt enric he's actually
running I'm very lazy do you actually
think no but that's the I be game speed
right that can't be like you are actual
character I think it's actually like my
characters like RPG speed like I don't
I'm so like if I made one I could be
faster well then that seems kind of ok
yeah right why did he run on slow-mo
that's just hey he's all strength baby
it's all on the muscles he's he's braun
strowman not the fastest but by god does
he power slam you into the mat is it up
those stairs there we go yeah yeah it's
card selection
oh we're gonna fight Bobby Roode right
off the bat no prep or hideo itami I
feel like I could just do a promo
no no promos we want to fight it's gotta
be Bobby Roode oh I hear shins K's music
but he's already you know technically
Bobby Roode's not even in NXT anymore
okay fair we're gonna fight Bobby Roode
on our opening opening night here or
debut night rather debut match which
basically you know what's gonna happen
that's how Baron Corbin in a training
mission and he literally just what are
you even doing here
nice yeah and is cooler my glass window
uh uh guys at any idea of the Destiny
series servers are live yet no I don't
know I don't think so follow Bungie help
that would be the easiest way on the
Twitter's or GameSpot news will probably
on that but on to our debut match we are
young Ben Janka no but you're about to
fight a former NXT champion
depending on the time depending on the
time of when we are kind of going back
in time here a little bit but I feel
like you'll get at least a hidden or
watch them out so he's gonna do some
work you feel like kind of exactly he's
gonna be like hey Ben alright take it a
little easy on you tonight I will let
you have a good intro I'm gonna turn up
the music
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Osito
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the best children he had no know what
the device is called a bit one of the
pay-per-view or dependencies on
pay-per-view but like one of the
matches he has one of those little crane
things and like lifted him all the way
up oh it is okay obviously
oh you can do that yeah you can
disrespect them such for you you're not
that glorious oh we got that hit him we
got that hit is oh all the belt on Oh
take his belt keen hit him with the belt
oh yeah like the disrespect that you
displayed although in terms of damage
you guys are pretty on par oh yeah none
of that giving that Cesaro uppercut I
like it then oh okay ten countdown
it's a raised hand right he's out so the
[Music]
cancellous match oh facebuster I like it
you know I could do it again oh here we
go oh yeah we get the belt what do we
have the belt that's all I need to know
we straight up what just happened the
key he's had to be he'll you had to get
that early advantage while he was you
know strutting his way down the walkway
huh he was dumb enough again the ring to
get to get punished
call me right in great I love it
[Music]
easy you're definitely not getting the
belt for that but in our mind we're the
champion what a debut this been Janko
what a heel
Baron blade oh yeah he's a fighter like
that how'd you do my boy dirty like that
me not the kind of impact you want to
have that's a perfect way keep running
that angle see the heel angle yeah
someone's got to be the evil in this new
NXT how what do you why do you now
oh you exit he arena this guy's having a
rough time he's texting his mom
day one very well lowing clock is there
any micro transactions like bf2 so there
are loot boxes but we're all from money
God if you can't pay to wear anything by
oh you think so
it's all saying that guy equals Cena and
Lesnar's love child
Bobby blade talk to you ooh bin was mr.
Balor at
there is no microtransactions it's just
virtual currency just want to clarify
that make sure everyone knows it's not
pay to win or pay to look good or
anything now you can basically open up
[Music]
I have a car sick myself what a debut
grab my car I'm gonna go celebrate my
first victory yeah security guy go get
my I don't know what do you think you
guys that is a very economical car sir
oh yeah smart man
all about the mileage you gotta you got
to be smart about it
that's very kind of you to say some
other people were not so so into the
into the look but you know not you
that's pretty quick
what's his name no way Jose I don't even
know an excuse at March I'm just kind of
like no way to take out that Bobby
really yeah yeah no way Jose company man
pelipper is not feeling the looks isn't
that the one guy from insanity maybe
Richard Morales I don't follow an X to
you that much I only know a little bit
the fact that I even know who no way
Jose is already like yeah it's a pretty
good one he's pretty good show them what
you got got it do they're gonna heal it
again or I'm basically sent insanity not
insanity but sandy sure I know kind of
rough with a group you're talking about
it's headed by an Eric something
not me though not Eric K is an area here
I'll look it up that's what having the
PC here it goes the Eric Young yep Eric
down see oh hey oh no Eric Young Nicki
cross Alexander Wolfe and Killian Dana
oh that was a guy from sanity think
there is some kind of slightly different
and more Tassie's this could be an old
breakout town did you hear that no they
know Ben Jenkins mic up because I can
kind of talk very
three times hopefully that helps if not
I'll just have been talk louder well
that's how it goes thanks Anthony's
statin would you this match and then
we'll looking out and there's some more
exciting things
whoa whoa debut match beating Bobby
Roode and you know look at this so I
gave myself at number one daddy beat
that KFC is a colonel in the game yet I
know you so a part of the game I don't
know
we need the colonel we need the
Colonel's
almost how's it like
oh look you I could not do that real
life don't sell yourself short
okay well we get a better look at that
later though okay yeah yeah oh no no
wait the game generates custom people to
fight against no I think this guy's
right
you can't download some characters into
the game as we mentioned a little bit
earlier and we'll show you that in a
little bit
you got a bunch of a bunch of silly ones
that were pretty fun that you can
download I didn't know this until then
told me so we'll show you how that works
and who you can get go through some of
them
I look up this guy he's got to be a real
good
yeah Chris hero Casius oh and no and he
does to wear jersey like that oh no his
actual real name is Chris hero idea or
Chris sprawl it in Spradlin Chris
rattlin he's older than me though holy
crap and I'm old hmm all right here you
go
here we go more like oh yes for us
oh dude you
you could've did what uh whoa wasn't
having it
oh no rude was not having it I like how
he's already down from your one like me
buster Oh always give it back to you I
can't believe this we didn't hear the
glorious DDT Wow Wow
what okay it's loading what what okay
you have solidified yourself in the
annex teaser that Bobby Roode decided to
come out and took a time out of his day
to come down to my match and give me the
business yep mm-hmm all right well that
was that anyway that's my career my
career whatever it is it's got it are
there any other modes we should check
out before we rumble or should we just
really this probably would just all
right rumbles it is oh he liked it he's
like yeah that's exactly what we wanted
way to get work to my dude yeah that can
happen at times what okay geez
yeah I know right like guess that's why
he's Champa Box going down
sweet cool this is my favorite music
yeah
this is my career yeah story mode but
we're gonna get out of this right yeah
we're just gonna go do some fun stuff
now but we I think we had a pretty good
debut now we're on like rude [ __ ] list
which is good which means you know
you're gonna get TV time exactly the
loading is longer than match that's
actually fact in that case but oh
[Music]
[Music]
funny this is a reason
bingo yeah EDS I needed that Tyler part
in the I do one regular match let's do
one with some big names maybe we'll let
chat pick alright who do you guys want
to see in a 1v1 who who do you want Ben
to play and who do you want Ben to fight
the names that come up the most is what
we'll pick I know there's some delay so
I'll let you guys kind of figure that
out oh yeah Batgirl Batman I'm just
saying there's you could you could also
just have been Janka fight as Ben Janka
you got the Burger King got Cammy you
got Chi eight yeah that's yeah it's
pretty good coach Jack Sparrow let's
imagine Crash Bandicoot CrossFit Jesus
who looks a diva a weird female
dodgeball yeah Deadpool got okay that's
awful the doctor from this race or not
mr. Spang the doctor from Doctor Who
sorry dr. Jimmy Russell Duke Nukem kind
of kind of chew gum and kick some ass
Goku with John Cena's face oh yeah jason
voorhees okay Team Rocket Wow we got a
lot of good on someone said Batman three
Batman's or the same guy saying that
three times
cheater can't be doing that this guy
what is that the mask okay Mike MJ
himself
mr. clean that's a pretty good miss
please Naruto with okay I I can kind of
dig it there's good old Pikachu okay
there's ash ketchum or the guy that I
thought was Terry Bogard Wow one punch
man yeah sure
Oh
shredder all I say is oh it's go away
Nia I don't like I say the rumble is
gonna be a lot of fun yeah great
I'm loving this some of these are really
good now you know the brass bands okay
nobody so a couple of Batman's RVD funny
thing is I have some means of his
brother but your gifts that I could play
right
okay Batman who do you want Batman to
fight sure I saw mr. Queens name earlier
let's do it
who do you think will win though
okay we'll see okay mr. mr. clean could
be a sneaky a sneaky guy that's good
it's even even that so why a triple H uh
no it's not time to play the game but
when is it time to play the game I don't
know you have to ask Stephanie McMahon
never figure out yeah that EDM music
doesn't he owe me yeah her new because
she has the glow shoes yeah I don't know
again I don't know I know these things
that's good
some WrestleMania 32 Brassel mania 30
second WrestleMania featuring Batman and
mr. clean is the main event
Skeletor yeah yeah that was a good one
to you he's a good dude I'm really
excited to see these load times though
Ben you're the real talk real talk they
are not the greatest I also feel like
the load times are kind of dependent on
the complexity of the characters you're
loading which is the downside if you
like to do the custom characters like I
do a lot is sometimes so you're saying
the load time there was longer because
of who we are playing
oh yeah from Gotham here he is
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen is now a hero okay
Ubaldo family 210 pounds six one what
are they what are they get a man dude
you know what okay hey yeah his cape
[Music]
yeah it's yeah this is what happens when
you make some Justice League DC
characters in WWE
oh it's okay now down in the ring so get
in the ring throw in the ring
Oh are you in the ring cleaned us fight
fair though he didn't hit you until the
[Applause]
like sharp Oh worried about to find out
[Music]
hurt his handle over what I heard 35
East was backed up for hours this
afternoon
with fans hoping again yeah we're in
traffic updates that's that's yeah yeah
you better you better stay out there
[Applause]
yeah root for the bats oh yeah take them
down oh yeah mr. cleans back has seen
better days oh you guys submission moves
- oh yeah what is the the Batman
I could see Batman you know training in
the arts of the Brazilian jiu-jitsu
jiu-jitsu rather oh yeah really working
on mr. cleans bag making it hard for him
to walk around this is great they want
you to talk more into the mic then I'll
try to boost you some more hear me yeah
real sensual you're talking about
wrestling rasslin how do you feel about
wrestling oh I don't like mr. clean
doing that sir clean that man oh he's
giving it back to you it's very rude boy
I just lower the gameplay to hopefully
that helps if you feel like you need
more gameplay I can boost that back up
though I also turned up Benz gains a
little bit so hopefully not only does
his muscles start to explode but his
his audio started to get a little bit
it's just oh no were you trying to
counter traversal have we ever played
have you ever played forbidden siren Ben
[Music]
this is something I would see Batman
doing to you you know giving you the old
go to sleep but here we are mr. clean
yeah teach them how to really do it ah
one of those kind of kind of resent her
everything yeah now we're not pinning
him yet oh yeah what is this I don't
know
Oh God how is your leg feeling game play
to low now okay bringing it back up
I mean pelipper that's the thing you
know it's fake you just kind of got to
enjoy the moment oh that's a nice slam
there Batman having to clean up the
streets okay hey there's only one person
here who cleans things up yeah Batman
it's not mr. clean scoop slam wonder
what your special is it is it the Brock
Lesnar the f5 instead that was no we
want more I want more damage then we're
not painting him just yet
he's this is real WrestleMania but he
didn't go down after one finish fair for
those of you that know a little Ric
Flair chopped whoa what is a badass he
just stared you in the face didn't even
try to counter some sweet Dodgers oh
you're in trouble
Michael Cole says you're in trouble this
could be it what was that many frogs how
much gas do you have left here you're
Batman you should have all the gas in
the world so much gas oh is this
injustice twos new 3d mode no
unfortunately not
hmmm yes some type of do these skins
come with a game where DLC are the
official basically ninja baseball Batman
these are all characters who can
download for free right so we can show
them how to do that in a little bit
before we get into the hot rumble man
but we're gonna put all the funniest of
fun characters in yeah that is your go
to that a little oh we gone for that leg
bend again stretch a punishing stretch
been mister so strong pressing buttons
in his legs did cut him up though oh
[Applause]
well clothesline from hell
oh he's got his own trying to cut you up
but you got a mask so he'll never know
that really reminds us reminds me of
Jeff Hardy's good rock Lesnar
yelling glorious how's mr. clean still
uh-oh that that's a very important thing
for them yeah
[Applause]
no mr. clean is coming back into form
that man he's hurting the Batman
he's telling him he's the one that does
the cleaning not Batman
like I always still smiles
it's very keeps going and going and
going and going your favorite that and
the ID bus he has anything else okay so
there's been jank I have a lot more
moons oh you're like you're torn up a
bit I like that well damage does that
called the chiropractor I don't know
maybe we could call it that fella look
at that look at a little rolling a frog
splash these highlights you can't see I
like this oh yeah even a DDT stuck
that's how
[Music]
I missed that that's what we got
what is your I'm guessing favorite
horror game Ben that's from Bobby and
then the follow-up question is what's
your lawyer first
rs.20 and pitfall
what a match that was ladies and
gentlemen thanks
you're joining us
[Applause]
can't think of like it way back back
then for me horror game wise but I'll
just go PT cuz I still remember being
scared by that game and then wrestling
first wrestling game was the n64
whatever that are you want to show them
quickly how to get those characters into
their game if they were to so this is uh
this is a quick showing of how you would
download Batman or mr. clean or any of
these characters in what you have you
can download up to twenty a day that's
pretty cool so these are all character
created by the community right
[Music]
some old schoolers hole poked in there
I'm guessing you have most of like the
kind of like outlier a weird kind of any
time I saw some hope any wise I cool
just get a range of like stuff it
automatically all out okay and would you
say that download speed timewise is not
too bad or just kind of like set it and
kind of like there would be something
wrong oh nice okay cool they even got
China today we got Raphael yeah I got
oh the dark sick there's eight Bane's
venom wow there's a lot more someone
there's Big Poppa Pump right there what
Scott Steiner
okay so yeah if you guys are curious
that's how you get more characters that
the community made either some are
variants or some are kind of crazy ones
like the Rick Sanchez they just saw mr.
clean but yeah you can download 20 a day
and then you can kind of just wait for
your countdown go away 35 minutes for
Ben he'll still probably be on the
stream so we can try downloading
something too if we want to carnage cool
sure Scotty 2 hotty oh man he do the
worm great and Harambee himself alright
cool so let's do a rumble with set
characters is this one you need me to
kind of like go down gameplay is driving
up Ben I'll try to turn it down so get
it signed up by the bounty the money's
just it's too much yeah do I need to go
to camera real quick we're gonna hide it
for a second so you guys don't see it
real quick who's in this how long do we
got like a good 40 minutes all right
let's go through 30
there's gonna be a heck of a time yeah
it's never you put that someone asked
earlier is there four player co-op like
local co-op yeah or like now local co-op
but look what local battle I guess said
it should I uh I'm gonna know okay
they're not gonna be able to guess who
daddy beefcake is but the stream should
know already though it's all good okay
not not too worried about I might just
be able to just pick every one that pops
up so eight for the sake of sounds good
going out this roster
yeah nice tie ben says the hardcore they
know me hopefully
oh no we will you know what maybe I'll
play as myself on this rumble and see
okay how long sounds good
you should send yourself out later I
know you don't get to choose well so you
get the first two entrances and I'll be
able to do my own shrinks got it thanks
hardcore
be the boss because like that like him
he's got the brass knuckle yeah boss
legit
I would enjoy seeing some gameplay soon
we're getting there we're getting that
we got to pick our fighters here we're
setting up a 30 man Rumble free we can't
show you who's in the rumble oh that's
that's yeah we gotta put them yeah we
gotta put that one in there yeah we
wanna you know make sure you guys have a
fun experience so that you know you
don't know who's coming in necessarily
if the roster is looking pretty good
though so far this is yes mm-hmm
I agree yeah we'd speed it up though
Enzo amore his team can only get us so
far true there would you imagine 30
people is a lot of people yeah turns out
yeah we unfortunately can't kick Colonel
Sanders in because we didn't he hasn't
downloaded in him and we have a
35-minute I don't know one of them oh
really
I got got trick okay we're almost there
like three more got we got a couple more
to go gotta get that one man offering if
you guys don't know who he is
he helps on our sister site GameSpot
universe they he does some wrassling
coverage and also some other stuff but
if you haven't checked out GameSpot
universe you should check that out they
do a bunch of cool entertainment stuff
breakdowns on shows Rick and Morty Twin
Peaks the preach preacher budget oh good
go back okay going back so we'll see how
long been last I want to come in at the
beginning is myself and then we'll let
it go from there okay but this is a
thirty man Rumble it's gonna be a mess
all created characters all downloaded
all made by people so sick here we go
buckle up it's gonna get bumpy I think
we find I there's there's twenty percent
of me is worried that something might
glitch out oh really not see the end of
it
okay well we'll find out but well we are
about to find out if the rumble if we
survive the entire rumble because we do
have a lot of uh character character
created stuff and we'll see I'm hoping
we make it to the end I hope you daddy
beefcakes
daddy beefcake makes it to the end we'll
find out I hope you're ready to hear and
see Bobby Roode's entrance again because
I still that's okay that's fine yeah
totally fine do you think you come out
first
oh oh I wow you're gonna try to complete
survive oh yeah
okay 29 other people
does she not say anything she does it's
okay is there no soundtrack this year
all here's w be wrestling music I
actually turned off the soundtrack
because as it turns out I don't want to
hear disturbed every time I turn on the
game fair enough
not down to get down with the sickness
[Music]
[Music]
sponsored by KFC sneakers smart - I use
that camera angle can't actually tell if
your lips are in sync with what they're
saying you're always sure
just wait mmm fried chicken it's your
boy
I hope you're ready
[Music]
uh Lex well it could be just that I
turned down the commentary or I turn
down gameplay overall Wow and a fanny
pack
it's a fuzzy fanny pack okay
oh but yeah also there's a little bit of
a I tried to fix that wow it's just part
of your attire now yes yeah dang you you
are styling there I just want to make
sure everyone knows I'm here by turning
every sadi beefcake light on me in the
arena at the same time fun fact I
actually whisk burning up every time I
do this entrance is almost too much that
I could see that why are they showing
Maurice on the is that is that part of
your thing yeah okay I didn't know that
I've got to tell me these things you
said I didn't know that look part of
your intro we're going on a dream I see
a KFC during a campaign are you
personally sponsored by KFC I like that
you have the type oh you are literally
yourself right KFC and tell them to
sponsor me nice but they never respond
so I just went to church
turning just who is the most dominant
super versus maybe Saints Row funny
enough it's the same it's me it's always
me daddy beefcake daddy boy
Oh Big Poppa Pump yeah how do you flip
over this thing to forgot whose entrance
of his book like someone it's a good
question where's where's the Burger King
that's a good question where's the
burger
oh I'm surprised no one's made Ronald
McDonald okay and you're you don't like
clowns so I guess I mean oh I'll go for
a while McDonald's just so I can have
someone to fight the Burger King yeah
the Burger King the king the king
himself did that jack-in-the-box die yet
have a saddle man fast food battle
what do you mean jack-in-the-box is too
niche that's the go-to wouldn't it's
late at night that's true and they have
very very cheap tacos that are pretty
good yeah turns out if you guys didn't
know $0.99 tacos at Jack in the Box is
actually soybean and not actually meat
oh I did not know that I learned
something today
there you go so you're kind of eating
healthy yeah I mean in a way if you if
you think about it enough oh lordy its
crash if it isn't old crash himself whoa
it's crash
yeah it's actually like an attachment
that just showed up one day and I have a
baby
riding it out whoa this guy's really
orange I feel like everyone's gonna use
Bobby Roode's entrance - it's a good
default of fall I'm gonna definitely
make my own there's so much going on in
this game I figure that flexing the guns
it's doing the crash guns crash came
here to play don't have to look out for
him just me and him in the ring at the
beginning eventually you're gonna
destroy this guy I hope so is this live
you bet it is we see you spudley Dudley
oh really your go-to Oh work your
appendages to weaken daddy beefcake sure
he's a quick one this Crash Bandicoot oh
here we go
eight seconds till our next who's it
going to competitors gonna run down oh
my goodness the Dark Knight himself here
he comes
no cape shut up get out of here Batman
II don't want to deal with you I'm doing
with a a wild Bandicoot right now on the
ring oh here we go oh oh you should
could you have tried to clothesline
Batman off the oh man this has gone
quick bad yeah we get our next dude it's
starting to already start going oh no
who's it gonna be
that me and my dude it's Burger King the
Burger King you think the Burger King
name is talking about him where was
Burger King he was here there's a king
himself run Ben oh no he's angry
oh well Burger King survived yeah that
would have been a heck of a thing we was
a love Batman try to get I dare you
where is she where the drugs Rachel
Rachel I'm wrestling for you oh there
you go Michael Jackson I'm ready for my
office Susan come look at that gold
leotard my dude oh my goodness my dude
this is gonna be bad for you oh don't
let him moonwalk oh oh look at look at
you
oh hello reversal by the king Oh what
are we gonna do - MJ Oh Billie Jean is
not your lover oh he's trying to get
crash out of here
alright who's it gonna be leaning back
also back swag punch action going on
there made some improvements my move sir
Oh mr. clean wanted vengeance on Batman
well you ready took care of Batman
Oh Michael Jackson is bleeding now Oh No
his nose probably shattered into a
million pieces
Oh mr. clean it's your turn let's go now
this is fun this bill of Eliot I know
right we had all mr. clean says not
today oh oh don't let him don't let him
eliminate you take him out
come on take him out all the minions
come on this makeup will meet us we got
all the escape got out oh no watch out I
have to turn my attention to minion he
can't be allowed to live no he can't
yes hit up Lucy James if you are want to
know or doing sending minion pictures
she apparently
is into the minions I think or it's a
troll thing oh yeah outta your the grip
is strong on this one I can't believe in
I can't believe Crash Bandicoot still
live look at him struggling there in the
corner and Burger King just like ya buy
something buy some Burger King oh we got
Jason Voorhees so we're coming into the
ring does he have his machete hopefully
he doesn't oh no he's very tall but he's
he's a big man and he obviously killed
someone in the back I guess so
he's bloodied up maybe he finished off
Michael Jackson who who we just got rid
of oh no stay away we mean that no harm
Jason oh no no not like this oh no now
like this bad I'm so high up in the air
we need someone else to enter yeah yeah
yeah we need his attention oh he's just
staring at people like playing I'm so
I'm playing as myself Lancaster is that
a weird guy that you made I don't even
know what that is it's it's kind of like
a smurf that look at an inverted smurf
it's like a weird Rick and Morty monster
you would see you know oh he's a big
dude though he's a big dude all right
there we go get that Bulldog these are
not DLC we are actually playing Ben is
playing his own character as you can see
half of his what he's wearing is pretty
representative in the game these are
created by the community you can
download these funds like Captain Jack
Sparrow is gonna join the spray cuz you
know he's looking for that sweet
treasure he's cruising for a bruising
win I just think of that lonely only
the Lonely Island song with Michael
Bolton yeah yeah yeah Jack Sparrow house
like that's a good one if you haven't
seen that one
that's definitely highly recommend yeah
same people that did I'm on a boat and
all those fun fun things oh no yes or no
I created you I can put you down oh no
no no no no Ben oh he's so strong Ben
he's so strong man fight your way out of
it so you fight Oh
Krang the brain monster himself is
coming to join the fray you don't know
Krang he's from Ninja Turtles that is
yeah that is very much praying without
the brain in the in the in the middle
buttons the brain oh it does it's just
like a picture oh that's great
turn around we need to see this page
someones breathing now I hope it's a
minion oh yeah oh no no no captain
Dexter you crane is just so good Oh
cranes looking for a finisher now get
Iron Man Tony Stark is joining the fray
[Applause]
that's a legit Krang though yeah I know
I'm telling you that is a pretty legit
Krang oh he's getting rid of mr. clean
or he's trying to oh
Jack Sparrow he's doing I don't know a
lot is quite a bit you're gonna you're
gonna Bulldog Bulldog Jason Voorhees you
know he's gonna do to you when he
figures out that it was you I'd like to
see him try being I'm gonna take him for
a ride okay use that Oh crane into the
corner that minion is a tough cookie I
agree he has been in this match way too
long Jack Sparrow's slowly walking his
way away oh good good dodge there ooh
ooh
iron man just watching he's like oh the
double-team here oh you just
don't let me do their thing oh no Ben
just wants our bulldogging again look at
look at the Lancaster trying to get
Krang out of here what's going on in the
corner here
oh you slapping Iron Man no we were
friends oh no he's going to try to daddy
be cakes is done I'm not going to Tony
Stark okay
the only Stark was not having it though
no oh boy he's is out mr. clean cleaned
him up yeah yeah you got to get in there
cuz I see that this has been going on
yeah this kraang action in the corner
straight up yester was never actually
trying to get him out of the ring yeah I
didn't even realize I tell you brought
to my attention that they've literally
been doing the same thing in the corner
this whole time it's a bit can't Iron
Man fly no he can't
Iron Man is just watching reversal take
out the music alright who we getting in
next not safe for work says Gucci right
I don't know I think it's alright yeah
Philip Elliot says no Jason oh it's a
minion finally done guile Giles here I
wish I could play the guile theme but I
would have to look it up and it's too
late are you guy all right now yeah mr.
clean oh there we go
lay him out okay let me see if I could
find the guile team a guile theme goes
with everything I could play it too I'm
pretty sure yeah it's video games
Biron why do you think the change of
plans here oh we took out miss don't
know how loud it'll be those I'm gonna
try turning it down there's some guile
theme I would have seen we can't hear it
but you guys should get over there
oh god says no get out of here
you are so much cooler than Lancaster my
guess is a very big guy Oh Hercule Satan
he's here everyone's favorite here we go
that's done that's done with hope you
enjoyed it hope it worked out the way I
thought it would Oh
Lancaster that furry monster out of here
Mon you you're gonna kick bison ass
after this oh come on what if he
reverses you okay good he's a strong guy
no the minion says Matt and Nicholas
yeah the minions out of here thank God
cranes hanging on by a thread here oh
the doc the doctor himself is coming
making a house call
here we are Doctor Who looking dapper
@af
oh it's gone literally just got rid of
him was in there for a second you're so
rude
oh my goodness one second and he's out
of there I guess the doctor had to go
back Oh Tony hanging on by a thread are
we got over ten seconds our next
competitor oh man
always Iron Man gonna get rid of another
one Krang fighting for his life guy like
Joey Lancaster dr. Jimmy Russell's
coming in you got another doctor doctor
doctor Timothy Russell coming in also
making a house call oh man
Hercule please Oh is he gonna try to get
rid of you oh look at Krang getting
retired man goodness
[Applause]
dr. who where oh he's gone
that's correct goob that that might be
the fastest intimidation I think I've
seen old crane so far
Jimmy Russell's Oh
praying with the escape oh you just get
suplexed
it's Goku Goku is it Super Saiyan Goku
or is he just run walls on the field
right now oh here he comes
Oh a double clothesline what a monster
it's okay guy I'll take a rest you
deserve it
let's just hope that uh Goku just keys
in on mr. satin here I feel like are we
gonna have it another but oh no Krang
decided that he did not want to be stuck
in the corner exactly no one puts
training how many it doesn't tell you
how many yet I have gone in the
Eliminator Oh No Russell's acne Duke
Nukem the Duke himself he is coming it's
actually really good chew gum came here
to kick ass and kick ass is all out of
it I think our chances are fine Oh Goku
okay survived somehow it's his hair yeah
Wow the actions picking up we got
another competitor on its way in five
seconds who's it gonna be who's it gonna
be it's a sight to my one punch himself
one punch and it's coming to one punch
everybody is he gonna throw a hundred
normal ones or is he gonna go and fight
seriously must have been 100 normal
punches because cranes still alive
oh coke who's gone rust dr. Russell's
gonna get rid of two oh my goodness
oh my lord e2 eliminations Oh pick up
the next one coming these Dukes got a
good set of moves does he's
real strong oh not no no no oh
real-deal is coming at Matt elf brings
character can we win the rumble and
out-of-work circuit city employee trying
to find his way in the WWE rest in peace
Circuit City his kids are in the
audience Oh someone just got eliminated
I missed it the Washington is trying to
do them Oh Duke is gone oh come on Jimmy
Russell's with the reverse do it for
your kids do oh come on Matt I'll bring
oh my god oh now now they're just
teaming up oh oh sanctum I got
eliminated come on that's not real life
he would have my do just there we got
him
that's real deal eliminates mr. Satan he
earned his meal tonight his family's
gonna eat everything is good this is all
you need to know man you got two big
brawlers here kraang has lasted a very
long time not gonna lie next competitor
a history of yeah since we might need to
take him out Oh Rick Sanchez no oh look
at Krang so nimble Oh No
oh here he comes science prevails oh
dude he's doing work who knew Rick
Sanchez could head hand-to-hand combat
experience gonna bring the the Szechuan
sauce slam oh yeah eat that sauce Morty
we go here you go here we go real deal
we gotta go wrestle Morty it's the only
way we can save the universe morning he
could chew himself itself whatever oh
come on get rid of do it for your kids
do us over consider your first Circuit
City Oh Chris Sanchez trying to get rid
of craying here the two biggest guys in
the ring are possibly gonna get
eliminated oh he's too sure they're both
two strong apparently wheeler Bobby
Knight oh here goes Pikachu there he is
oh my god get off my dude Oh Oh Jimmy
Russell just kind of cracking his neck
because no Pikachu is the wily one he's
almost like a Lucha Libre Rick Sanchez
is out Pepsi man Pepsi man the Pepsi man
is about to show up oh no oh my god what
is that even this Pepsi man oh is it
from that one game where like you run
around since Pepsi man yeah I think we
did that during extra life last year
it's a perfect game for extra life yeah
Oh Pepsi man's gonna get rid of
Russell's I hope so Oh Pikachu's he's
like a Lucha Libre like I said can you
student invoke his life
can you help them help Pepsi man get rid
of Russell's what are you doing Naruto's
coming take a rest man ninetails himself
oh he's Howard up it's it's the legit
version too he's pulling off hard up
Phil Elliott saying cranes gonna win I'm
feeling Krang might take it bori e65 won
oh my god Pepsi man best video game ever
yeah Pikachu does not have ears Matt
Marcel you are correct
Oh Krang is hanging on by a thread will
Naruto Hokage of the hidden leaf Naruto
we go nope
turns out crank up the ghost who's the
ghost okay real scary yeah too spooky
for me he's pretty much almost like nude
it's like it's almost like that one guy
from God The Watchmen except it's he's
white instead of blue oh no the real
deal Pepsi man is looking to get rid of
the wheels and Naruto is hanging on by a
thread clearly Oh
chasidy be saying this is ridiculous I
love it so much it is pretty awesome
Oh mister freeze whoa give up give me
some freeze puns been what killed the
wrestlers there you go the helmet I'm
not into but the actual face is pretty
close it was
oh he's after Pepsi man he must be he
must like his coke more than Pepsi I
used to meet you oh no okay maybe one
more one more one more
oh I looked these up last time then
[Music]
dr. Manhattan that's correct Jake Claus
oh thank you who's bleeding someone's
brains
kind of bleeding but he's already
bleeding from earlier man Russell's is
just hanging out in the corner Pepsi man
is doing work pretty much almost
tombstone that guy Oh drunk into crane
here to probably take brain out go he's
a Big East a big boy though it's not
gonna work Wow he even all muscle and a
stomach brain
I think belly is right maybe Krang will
win this I think we were starting to run
out of opponents I think there's like it
said earlier there's like 20 already
eliminated
oh the ghost mr. frito Pikachu doing his
best to get rid of Pepsi oh there's a
little to team action here mr. freeze
Pikachu trying to get rid of Pepsi man
Pepsi man hanging on by a thread
they're now both trying to kick him out
though Russell is just staring at
Naruto's back it's eerie as hell
Oh real deal come on to do for Circuit
City mr. freeze is also just staring
into Russell's back now everyone's on a
break yeah we'll go we'll go fix that in
a second here up there yep mm-hmm
they're just lining up okay it's getting
real awkward there we go
bulldog on mr. fries hopefully that
wakes them up always crank Oh Craig
somehow lives again I don't know yeah
clothesline
Oh mr. Pepsi's got a little submission
move now gonna walk him up to the rope
what is he okay we got our next
competitor soon oh you're trying to
choke out Naruto just go praying a Pepsi
man Fredrik everybody
Shrek coming into the match he believes
in his ninja way oh the trick just get
rid of someone I think so I feel like he
took out somebody he came in here and
just got rid of somebody man
Oh Pepsi man he's the champion in
everyone's hearts and Jimmy Russell and
Krang straight-up have been in this
since like five minutes ago
feels like a long time yeah we know
there's a bug in the corner of the Ring
Bobby that's kind of what happens when
you have all these characters look at
look at tricks bats just going through
his shirt
[Applause]
Jimmy Russell's just has been sitting a
lot smart move here letting everyone
else Hannah he's a doctor he knows
what's best yeah he's like guys just
leave me alone
whoa Naruto finally get an elimination
ooh he is just destroying God now he's
working on Russell's pranks is chewing
yeah he's like hey what's up guys
Oh Mr Freeze isn't having it though oh
my dude Kenny was a with Shrek 28 or 27
we're running out we only 13 and Rumble
was two more guests who could they be
not sure all I know is the real deal is
trying to hang on by a thread he's
seeking Redemption he's trying to do his
family proud he's trying to tell
everyone how important Circuit City is
all we could use gone with God Shrek
not a Pokemon fan clearly Frank dr. Mr
Freeze is still doing work oh here we go
29th competitor on his way
Oh Craig is so nimble for his size
let's see strong help me out front air
man I don't who is an air man up from
from Mega Man there you go another big
guy so strong for how big they are they
are all nimble even Shrek kind of doing
a rodeo there on the on the Oh
Naruto's gone air man comes in takes
care of business he is not messing
around
he kind of reminds me of Cobra
Commander's head piece I just I don't
know why mr. priest
what is Mr Freeze even in the fight he's
trying to get a stamina back ok real
deal is clearly the real deal because
he's surviving with these always going
to the top row I don't
here okay I like it I like your tactics
they'll never know oh my god shrek is
ope
he's pretty ope I don't know though
craying and Russell have seriously been
like since like in the teens yeah
they've they've been here for a very
very long time I'm not sure Bobby if
there's any did you see any intended
characters Zelda Zelda right yeah I
don't know if you put okay our last
final contestant who's it gonna be
hopefully it's not another big character
because coach for that I lied to you
guys it wasn't the last see look at all
the big dudes every time they get thrown
to the ropes they kind of do that little
off the ropes you know Sawyer comes
coach oh you like sock them right in the
face when you got in there's a lot of
big guys Real Deals gonna have to find a
way to hide out yeah yes demon Shrek
Princess Zelda question mark and on our
head uh-oh we got eliminated Oh Airman's
and mr. freeze I don't want I shouldn't
be hitting coach no you gotta be gone
for praying praying and Russell come on
coach go help coach help me it's okay
this is the final this is the final
who's it gonna be
[Applause]
oh no okay thought you're gonna get
tossed out shaggy sure yup here we go
here we go I'm very upset if Shaggy 2
dope Oh Shaggy 2 dope here we go oh I
think it's gonna be crying
I think it might be crying goop says Mr
Freeze got ice that is true I feel like
one of these big guys is gonna win this
and it's gonna Shaggy 2 dope take take
it easy all rustles dr. Roscoe Roscoe I
think I got that terminology right now
real deals got some moves I like it Matt
I'll see every time every time they just
do that little move and then and then
they're too strong for you to push out
no matter how hard you mash it doesn't
matter they're too strong
come on you're real zero for your family
you got to do this like mine get off me
he says knock knock knock really are we
going out too
all that's left is shrek this this is
the ultimate comeback we can do this oh
it's Rex not having it though for coach
coach can get tossed out here no Shrek
please this is the dream let this man
have his dream well the real deal
Circuit City former employee himself
survived the rumble Oh coach all the
restricts come on coach oh not today
coach no vitam vitamin deal come on do
it for your kids
do it hurry up shaggy help us Wow
is this gonna be the dream run here I
another hurricanrana if I'm getting that
wrong someone in chat told me I'm wrong
but I feel like that's the right move
Oh shaggy get out here we're trying to
get rid of the coach oh I survived you
know what my dude just stop please no no
no no coach toad please come on no I
don't just pose oh yeah there you go
there you go there you go
shaggy wants to he was not and who's not
you is not having it shaggy oh boy
Oh kick him out climb up you got this
you got this come on let's just let him
be
DDT oh you know he doesn't like that
it's true but I've got a finisher lined
up you got a finisher did it don't you
want to save it for a coach okay your
hate for him this is this is more
important than the winners look at coach
just hanging on my thread
shag your John Cena a little bit with
face paint Oh coaches back up Oh see oh
here we are
oh good dodge okay it's coach versus the
real deal Mon can we win with Matt elf
rings bring creative character not today
sir not today
we'll get the reset we'll get the
cinematic angle on this it'll be good oh
it's this steering eh oh oh oh oh no
here we are okay all right funny meeting
you here
in the ring of all blasts dance are
another hurricanrana oh he's so tired
you've been in the match for like a
while even getting beaten by Krang Jimmy
Russell oh dude he's he's here he's
fighting for his kids he needs this
coach just forget out of here to coach
he's got a family to feed come on coach
come on just let it be it's okay that's
right so right coach is a very resilient
wrestler he's athletic yeah he survived
he has to do what he preaches
she's never give up something something
chocolate helicopters back in yeah beat
him up
hit him a bunch Oh Ric Flair oh yeah go
for the leg yeah go bootleg yeah yeah
how's your like oh it also hurt us
apparently
real deal is running out of gas listen
can you get it done yeah there we go
can we get it done coach Oh what's the
finish no we're about to finish all real
deals could be ways this oh good left
hook I see if we can do this even right
here man say deal oh oh damn it coach
get out of here yeah the real deal he's
gonna go home he's got he's got food now
he can feed his family he's made his kid
he's a champ means he is our true stream
champion Wow for today I didn't go oh
look at him go I can't miss I'm so glad
he gets to go to Wrestlemania this is
what these waters that is
who would have thought not not I I did
not see that coming Ben that was awesome
okay guys so that's WWE 2k 18 I guess
the most fun you've had personally been
is all these fun kind of like Rumble
character created characters but the
story mode seems not bad especially if
you you're you're into wrestling you
want to go through kind of like those
the my career which is like a very 2k
thing to do it's been an MBA 2k and
things like that but yeah we reviewed it
we gave it a 5 out of 10 so obviously
not not the greatest but uh let me read
some of the pros and cons if you can
find stuff to like in this game you'll
like it
okay I recommend it if you like what you
saw yeah so yeah so some of the good was
there's a visual upgrade from previous
mammoth roster stars from various eras
exhaustive creation sweet a road to
glory adds a purpose a little purposeful
spin to the competitive multiplayer but
the bad is there's glitches as you guys
saw some of those in affecting every
match type of mode my career is a dull
slog is what the reviewer says not the
greatest writing and impotent promos and
react restrictive uses of loot boxes
that was from Richard way cling but yeah
hope you guys had fun with us today
we're live every day at 11 a.m.
we'll be live tomorrow I haven't picked
the game yet because I'm not sure but
it'll be fun nonetheless so if you guys
haven't liked subscribed all that stuff
you guys should do that so you get
notified when we go live and also when
we post up cool features gameplay all
that fun stuff but until next time Ben
thank you today for winning a rumble
with the real deal I didn't win it the
real deal that's true it was a victory
for the people that is 100% true until
next time guys see you later
buh-bye
[Music]